we need Pascal further in the Bundestag,
so that the actual concerns of employees also
continue to take a seat in the Bundestag.
so that student
engaged in their struggle for higher wages
be supported,
because one of the few is there,
who knows how important strikes are for us employees,
for better working conditions and higher wages
to enforce
and who supports us very much in our
Fare replacement
for better
Working conditions
in nursing and hospitals,
respectively.
in Berlin
we have for better working conditions at schools
streaked,
we have for better wages for all
employed in the public sector on strike.
Pascal was always there,
has supported us.
thanks for that
and also with Allen comingAuseinandersetzungen
we know,
Pascal is a strong ally,
who stands directly at our side.
Pascal is a great guy,
has always sat down with heart and mind
for the purposes of the dependent
Employees in the plants.
1 is one of the loud votes in the Bundestag
for work and social justice
is always firmly on the side of business.
such a colleague
we need in the Bundestag,
so choose him.